Hi, I'm Tom from the Burp Scanner development team. Today I'm going to talk a little bit about
automatic session handling in Burp Scanner. Now this is something I've talked about previously
regarding the crawl, but today I'm going to focus a little bit more on how the audit
automatically maintains session. So let's dive straight in with an example app that shows why
this is so important. So I've just created a little application here that has two pages.
First we're given a page with a greet me link and if we click on that we're given a page with some
pretty obvious reflection. However through some pretty basic cookie usage this page will only
allow five visits. So just keep refreshing it before eventually it says no. It gives me a 400 and says
please stop. So that means that if we go and actively scan this page, so if we do an active scan,
we're not going to find the reflection because when we start sending payloads to the page,
we've already used up our session for that page and we start getting 400s. Now if you're getting
400s, if you're not hitting the application proper, your payloads aren't reaching the attack surface and
you're unlikely to find any bugs and this is why session handling is so important. Now we could set
up a manual session handling rule here or what we could do is we could crawl and audit our application.
So if I open this up and I don't want HTTPS, I just want HTTP and I go to localhost,
8000 and I scan that. So what's going to happen here is Burp Crawler is going to explore the
application and it's going to find our vulnerable page and not only is it going to find it, it's
also going to figure out what steps it has to take to get back there again should it no longer be in
session. This information will be handed off to the audit and the audit will then try to find the
shortest viable path that still gets us there. So in this case, nine times out of ten or I guess
five times out of six, actually just hitting the same page over and again will work and it will
figure out, the audit will figure out that for the most part it could just keep sending the base
request and sending payloads in there. However, as those payload containing requests start to get
versions of the page that doesn't recognize, that it doesn't see as matching how it originally saw the
response when it was crawling, what it will do is it will stop and say, hmm, am I out of session?
The way it works this out is we go back to sending an unmodified base request. We want to work out
whether it's the payload that's causing an unexpected response or whether our session has died. So we will
send an unmodified base request. We will check to see if we're still in session. If we are, we'll go,
okay, well it's maybe just that our payloads are causing the application to hand us back different
responses, which is totally expected. If we're instead out of session, what we'll do is we'll go
back to the full path to get back to that location and we will re-walk it so that we go and get a
brand new session. After that we can go back to doing our simple path and keep sending our base
requests, keep putting payloads in it until it happens again. And in this way Burp Scanner will
continually make sure that all of the payloads it sends are in session. If it ever works out that it
has lost session, it will roll back to the last time it saw a successful session, last time
it saw a payload being sent and getting a correct response and it will rerun any scan checks that
have been seeing unsuccessful responses since then, just to make sure that we're getting maximum
coverage. So as we can see here from our crawler and audit, we found our reflection and we found
the cross-site scripting that goes along with it. Now this was a topic that was requested a lot by the
community because it's not something that we talk about a great deal. If you have any more
suggestions for things you'd like me to cover, just let us know.
Thank you.